I mean there's so many great moments
with hook and Emma I feel like I can
only talk from my own experience I
definitely like the moment where when we
went on our back to future little
adventure Emma taught hook had a
swordplay that was a fun moment yeah
there's there's been several really
sweet moments between them but I'd say
that one stands out it's kind of a
little bit different had its own little
spin to it more sense that we yeah maybe
close marry the romantic moments between
hook and Emma I think they're just
fantastic I know in episode 99 the
moment before hook has to sacrifice
himself is just so amazing you can be a
little biased well I'm gonna be biased
it's gotta be you win Prince Charming
wakes Snow White up when he first sees
her in that glass coffin and all the
dwarves are around her we film that in
the first season I remember we were way
out in the woods and it started to snow
that day when we went to film it so it's
pretty special there's been so many I
have to say I'm a huge Emilie de Ravin
fan I love the whole Belle dance but we
finally got the Beauty and the Beast
dance but that made my heart swell but
the show makes me cry all the time and
I'm in it so but there's just I think
that one really stuck out for me I love
a lover Belle and run for honestly I
think the most romantic moment was when
Charming woke it's no way table with the
kiss and that's that's what the show is
about you know it's about hope it's
about love it's about all the good
things in life and that's I think that's
what the shoulders really love I think
that's hard to say but maybe the maybe
the season for dance between bellow and
Rumple care to dance
I would say that the opening of the
series you know charming waking up snow
we wanted to start with the most iconic
true love moment of all fairytales and
everything sort of comes out from there
oh gosh there's been so many
um I think hook and Emma going on a date
was really kind of cute I think when we
got to dance at the ball that was kind
of sweet this gorgeous gal over there
laughs oh yeah and also we giggle a lot
together so it's rehearsing the dance
and stuff we just we we make each other
laugh a lot and so I just got really
really happy memories of kind of goofing
around
oh my well with my character kind of
overall whichever one you could be a
little biased
I'd say um you know really towards the
end of last season when we all started
become a family I think that's the most
romantic of all